- The Bank of England is issuing new bank notes,
beginning with the £5 note.
And they're made of plastic, and there've been
all sorts of advertisements that you can't break them.
I felt immediately: challenged
and I had the idea,
if we froze it with liquid nitrogen...
the strands of the polymer
would be frozen rigid...
and you may be able to break it—
hitting it with a hammer.
So I gave Neil several of my own £5 notes—
you can't spend university
money on things like this
—and he had great pleasure trying
to break the professor's bank notes.
And it worked!
He managed to smash one,
but it took several attempts.
You had to get the orientation
just right and hit it just in the right way,
and then it broke into two or three pieces.
Unfortunately, he lost one of the pieces,
so I couldn't glue it together and spend the note,
so it's a souvenir.
Incidentally, it's not illegal to break the
notes, though it's illegal to draw pictures
on her Majesty's face.
But Neil felt that this wasn't
really quite exciting enough,
so he decided to put this in his
special supply of fuming nitric acid.
It's a bit old, so it's gone brown,
so it may be even better.
Fuming nitric acid... and there's several sorts,
and I'm not sure what Neil's type was particularly,
but essentially, it is a mixture of
pure nitric acid—or nearly pure nitric acid
with N2O4 dinitrogen tetroxide added to it.
And N2O4 in itself can dissociate into NO2,
so it's quite a witch's brew
or perhaps I should say
wizard's brew in the case of Neil.
It is well know as being
a very powerful cleaning agent.
If you can't get muck off your glassware,
the last resort is fuming nitric acid.
Neil's hypothesis was that he could
completely dissolve it—it would just disappear
and he could have a solution of a £5 note.
What happened was actually much more exciting,
that when he put it in,
the queen's face quickly faded.
When he took it out, there was some
of the writing and stuff still left.
But it just brushed off quite easily
and what he was left with, to all our surprise,
was a completely transparent piece of plastic,
exactly the same size that he started with.
- yeah, lovely.
- I gave this sample to one of my
student who ran an infrared spectrum
and showed that it was polypropylene.
This is the plastic made from propyne.
When it says on the internet these
are made from polypropylene, they're right!
It's really fun. I now show this to
people and say "what do you think it is"
and they have no idea.
You can see that we did a proper
experiment in the sense that we had a control.
I insisted that they also use
one of the old paper notes.
The queen didn't fade as much on the paper note,
but when they had taken it out and dried it,
it was interesting that the note had
gained really quite a lot of weight.
And this was absolutely consistent with my idea
that the fuming nitric acid might
nitrate the cellulose of the paper.
This is adding NO2 groups to the paper,
and nitrated paper burns very
much better than ordinary paper.
It's used by magicians and conjurers
and it's the basis, in fact, of gun cotton,
which is used as an explosive.
It went with a real woosh!
And what was particularly interesting
is that it burned without any ash at all.
It just disappeared, and the reason
for this is that with the NO2 groups,
you have enough oxygen in the
note to make it burn to completion.
So we have a really nice
farewell for the old paper bank note.
It just disappears into thin air.
I must stress that we've done this in the
interest of science and because we think
it's an important and interesting experiment.
But, on the other hand, we are destroying
bank notes, and so we feel that it's only right
that we've given an
equal amount of money to charity
to show that we don't really want to
destroy money just for the sake of it.
I should say to you that if you
want to repeat these experiments,
there are probably cheaper ways
of doing it than using bank notes.